everyone knows inflation is absolutely
out of control but what the hell is
going on almost 80 percent of all u.s
dollars in circulation today have been
created in the last two years that's
right the us dollar is decades and
decades old but 80 percent of the
dollars that are in circulation were
literally created in the last two years
maybe that is why prices are starting to
rise you can't simply debase a currency
and not expect people to raise prices
what you're literally doing is you're
making the dollars less valuable so it
takes more dollars to buy the same goods
and services as you used to get now of
course we can simply talk about it we
can simply save the number 80 it sounds
like a big number but wait till you see
this chart my friends this is absolutely
bonkers eighty percent of the m1 is
literally in the last two years since
2000 we kind of skirted along and then
boom we went vertical favor watch top
gun we're going vertical baby and so
ultimately what we now have is 20 000
billions of dollars that's right 20
trillion is a big big number so
ultimately what's gonna happen here is
as long as this number keeps going
vertical keeps going up and up and up
and we keep creating more dollars prices
are going to have to increase if prices
continue to increase then inflation will
continue to remain at sustained levels
if all of a sudden we are over 2
inflation for multiple years that
compounding adds up fast and of course
people can say it's transitory it's not
the federal reserve has now retired that
word because they also know it is not
transitory on top of that if 80 percent
of the dollars were created in the last
two years as of right now if they
continue on this trend in a year we'll
be saying in the last three years 90 95
99 of all u.s dollars have been created
now i hope that they can get this under
control i hope that we go back to a more
disciplined monetary and fiscal policy
but if history
is any signal of what potentially could
happen in the future i would not bet on
it why because once politicians and
central bankers realize that there was
appetite for this type of behavior i
think they're going to continue to do it
more and more and more and so ultimately
what can you do at home simply protect
yourself learn what inflation is learn
how it works learn why it's happening
like this and make sure that you are
positioned to benefit from it because
when inflation hits the top 50 percent
or so of americans they benefit the
bottom 50 percent of americans are so
they get hurt by the top 50 own assets
the bottom 50 percent don't in an
environment of high inflation you have
to own assets you cannot save your way
to financial security as you save you're
literally just watching it get devalued
away savers are losers investors are
winners when inflation is high make sure
you learn about investing all kinds of
different markets so you can allocate
capital to but you have to invest invest
invest and the beauty of investing in
high inflation is that once you get
invested the government and the central
bank will pump those asset prices to the
moon and they will make you richer than
you ever dreamed